je suis con ça dure sur le poste de
responsable
les entretiens d'embauché fictif pour
etienne et laurence deux associés de
l'entreprise éphémère myriade de saint
quentin en yvelines
amira where any la coach observe pour
les conseiller sur les points à
améliorer
voilà une activité quotidienne pour les
membres de l'entreprise éphémère une
personne va jouer le rôle du candidat ou
là il va s'entraîner en faisant son
pitch et faire sa simulation
d'entretiens avec des questions qui lui
sont posées
après il ya une personne qui va jouer le
rôle du recruteur c'est un très bon
exercice pour moi d'être du côté
recruteur avec une des coachs et de
pouvoir aider mes mais mes collègues à
se positionner sur sur leur poste et à
voir ce qui va ce qui va moins bien
etienne lui joue le rôle du candidat
dans quelques jours il a un entretien
d'embauché dans une entreprise à
guyancourt une opportunité pour ce
consultant responsabilité sociétale en
recherche d'emploi au sein de
l'entreprise éphémère au fil du temps je
pense que nos chances individuellement à
tous de trouver du boulot de réussir des
entretiens de faire des réponses à des
offres pertinentes s'accroît
l'entreprise éphémère de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la deuxième
expérience en france le concept une
cinquantaine de demandeurs d'emploi
réunis pendant cette semaine pour
répertorier les offres de recrutement
sur le territoire à travers six services
est accompagné par trois coachs on va
confier à ta mission à telle personne
mais on va vraiment ciblées en fonction
de l'appétence et des compétences porte
à porte dans les entreprises prospection
téléphonique réception de représentants
de sociétés
au total les associés ont trouvé près de
650 offres d'emploi auprès de pme et de
grands groupes
ça c'est une carte qui a été déployée en
fait par notre service face à face afin
qu'ils puissent repérer le territoire
sur lequel ils vont prospecter au début
de la dernière semaine
onze membres de l'entreprise éphémère
ont retrouvé un emploi
seize sont dans un processus de
recrutement